get organized
because what we are dealing with
is an organized activity
calculated to destroy Polish agriculture
Polish statehood
Independence
Freedom of Poles not only in the economic dimension
I think most of you,
dear
Already yy understands it
that this is a game with chulers
We can't win this game.
Because as we learn yy better and better
How the card is getting better
The opponent changes the rules of the game.
This is exactly what has happened in recent years.
yy Brussels
over our heads with Kiev makes agreements
Over the dead if we don't stop it
Polish agriculture cannot be won in this game
you have to get up from the table with gamblers
who try to play us with marked cards
on
so announcement yet because yy some farmers
They share yy serious concern
When they come down from the border
When they suspend the protest
it's at home
Maybe a ticket to the army will be waiting for them.
These are serious concerns and they are,
uh
As the hysteria of warmongers grows
At the highest state level
these fears are fully justified family wives
mothers and fathers of farmers protesting seriously
They are afraid of such an attempt to pacify
Yesterday at a meeting in Podkarpacie yy the question was asked
for whom is a place made in Polish prisons
yes 2.000 yy free bunks
for whom you have to do yy in Polish prisons
and I am a member of the Sejm
Unfortunately,
I can not easily dispel these worries 1
and so yy who understands
that the question of war and peace is also at stake here
I invite you to protest
Peaceful protest
in Warsaw already in the election silence on April 6
We meet at the roundabout
Dmowski at 14.
yy poland for peace
yy stop yy warmongers
stop banderisation of the Polish raison d etat
This is not our war
God bless you
blessed feasts from the dead
and as he told me in biłgoraj yy
3 days ago 1 farmer yy
I do not wish health
because on the titanic everyone was fine
so I wish you luck
I wish you luck
and I these best wishes yy on you
Transmit here
with Lord God